and former backup singer mariah carey
took home two grammys for best female
pop vocalist and best new artist i'm
currently writing my second album and
i'll be in the studio recording soon
and i'm excited for it and i don't think
the pressure's there to top this maybe
in other people's eyes but in my own
eyes the only pressure is to make an
album that i'm proud of and that i feel
satisfied with
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i feel really fortunate um to have had
all the success with my first album that
i had
and
it's it's been the most incredible year
of my life with everything that's
happened for me but the most important
thing is to make good music that i'm
proud of
[Music]
with this album i had a lot
better of an idea
about how i wanted to go about recording
it it's just a lot more me coming across
and i feel that i had the opportunity to
let myself go and to be more true to
myself as a singer and a songwriter
because i didn't have someone there
telling me well maybe sing it like this
thing like that everyone that i worked
with it was a true collaboration
[Music]
emotions the single um was written by
myself and
um the team of david cole and robert
clavilla so i guess it's like late 70s
kind of early 80s r b
type of dance music that we were feeling
that day and we just sat down and
did the music and i took it home with
the lyrics because it seemed like a
really happy
song so
[Music]
this new video that i just did was fun
because there were a lot of people and a
lot of my friends
in it and i had a really good time in
the beginning it was a little bit like
anything it took getting used to and i
feel a little bit more confident now and
a little more comfortable with that
aspect of my career
so you know it's getting better
[Music]
i definitely wanted to let my voice
shine through as the lead instrument
more than covering up what i do with a
lot of unnecessary production we did you
know some songs have a lot of production
on the but we did whatever the song
called for some songs are just entirely
you know much more acoustically rooted
we i wrote a song with carol king on the
album and we did the entire thing
with a live band and we just did you
know three or four takes and that was it
we didn't mess around with computers or
things like that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i also wanted to write everything for
this album
and she said that she loved to write
with me so i was kind of in awe and in
shock and
i i was really into it so she flew in
from idaho because she lives in idaho
now on a farm
and we got together and we wrote the
song
if it's over in about an hour start to
finish and then she went home
[Music]
it wasn't like i planned to put out a
second album so quickly
um it just so happened that i was
writing while i was putting out singles
from my first album um and before the
album was even really successful you
know i had a lot of songs already for my
second album so i decided instead of
waiting like you know most people would
do just to put out the music because i
felt that i was growing as an artist and
i wanted to get that out there and show
that
[Music]
i don't have a tour planned right now
because i put out my second album so
quickly after the first album and i was
literally
locked in the studio for months i mean i
i went i ate and i slept there you know
it was like um so i didn't have time to
plan a tour like most people would have
been planning their tour after a
successful first album so i want to make
sure that when i do go out on tour it's
the best tour that i can do i don't want
to just throw something together because
that's the thing to do
[Music]
everything that i've done
in the past two years has been like a
gradual
process of just being overwhelmed by you
know the fact that this is actually
happening for me when you just dream of
something your whole life and it's it's
your whole focus and then you know
quickly things start to happen for you
it's amazing every everything from the
first time i ever heard my song on the
radio
to um the grammys last year which i was
totally overwhelmed and you know crazed
and amazingly happy i'd be worried if it
wasn't happening so i'm really happy and
i'm not going to complain
[Music]
one of my backup singers patrick
mcmillan introduced me to trey
like two years ago when i was doing my
first album and i was singing a song
called there's gotta be a way in the
studio and um we were actually mixing
the record and i kept hearing this guy
singing the high notes and i'm like
where's that coming from i know i didn't
sing that particular note and it was him
when i did i'll be there it was kind of
like a spur of the moment thing and um
needed someone to do the other part and
so
i was doing the mtv unplugged show and i
didn't have any plans to do a remake and
the people who do the show really really
wanted me to do a remake so finally um
at the the last you know like the 11th
hour basically it was like a day and a
half before someone said to me you know
they really want you to do a remake so i
just said um you know i thought about
and i decided i'll be there
and so then when we were doing it we're
rehearsing it you know i said this
really needs another person to sing
because i could have sung the whole
thing but i really felt it needed
another person so
i asked trey to sing it and it just
worked and we had never planned to put
the unplugged show out as an album or
anything out on video or anything and it
just happened to be that um i'll be
there i'll be there i came out as a
single
so you know worked out great for me and
for trey
fill your heart with joy
[Music]
when i'm
out here singing it's totally a
different perspective than when i'm in
there and even even when i'm
co-producing my own work
i can't really be objective about it
sometimes because it's me so i nitpick
everything that i do but working with
someone else that's a singer and you
know being a great singer sometimes
he'll sing something and he'll hate it
i'll be like i love it i love it leave
it and that's what everybody always does
to me so it definitely helped me get a
better understanding about letting
things go and leaving things a little
bit more loose and not always locking
myself into having to do it perfect and
do it over and over again so i think
it's definitely been a learning
experience for me the unplugged album as
well as doing trey's project
[Music]
you